[Music]
super excited to have you here thanks
for doing this today sorry for uh severe
my my first question for you is if I if
I open the Strava app right now and hit
record can we upload this as a verbal
workout to the platform
verbal and mental should be a setting on
the on the GPS watch for that I think
yeah heart rate where our heart rate
monitors we're good to go get the kom
for conversations right
I love Strava I've been looking forward
to this for a long time and I think you
know when I think about the platform and
and you know why I love it so much and
what it what what attracts me to it is
just the sheer positivity of the
community I mean it seems like on the
most fundamental level like there's a
wireframe there's a there's a there's an
architecture to it that isn't completely
dissimilar from something like Facebook
or even Twitter you post and there's
comments and there's a community but
it's so by comparison to other platforms
so overwhelmingly uplifting and and and
positive so how did you cultivate that
is that by design or did that happen
just by virtue of the target audience
that you're going after or what do you
attribute that to I think it was
definitely by by its inception we wanted
to try to create that feeling of being
part of a team being being connected to
other people who share whether it's your
passion for what you're doing or a sense
of just liking that camaraderie liking
to liking being with each other and so
the first step in that is really just
thinking through how do you get these
people to interact about the right stuff
and not the wrong stuff and I don't know
that we've we nailed this day one we
used to you we used to drop you into
your activities not into the activities
of other people yeah that was great for
some of our audience but for most people
what they want to know they want to know
there's a world out there that's you
know these people are out there they're
not them they want
focus on that that's the source that
their motivation so I think it is by
design it's very much that sense of
before we even knew exactly what's
travel was gonna be it was gonna be
about that sense of being on the team
again being part of a group of people
again yeah I remember my early you know
initiation to the platform I was a
pretty early adopter I it must have been
I don't know maybe late 2008 how many
numbers is your athlete ID I don't know
I should look yeah that's pretty much
the early I mean I wasn't like one of
the first people on the platform but it
was back in the days when you were very
specifically targeting cyclists and in
particular like the hardcore cyclists
the data freaks and it just seemed to
magnetize that community as a place
where everybody could kind of exchange
not just data but stories and community
around the riding so what was the
thinking in going after that community
first with the sense that you would
later broaden it it's one of the great
ironies of Strava is it neither Michael
or I are cyclist by background you have
done triathlons and we were runners we
met on the crew team so rowers and so
forth but if you fast forward to 2008
2009 we saw an opportunity to go to
market strategy really it was an
opportunity where that audience you just
described data-centric
investing in the technology like the
Garmin devices on their on their
handlebars and so forth and really no
one was addressing it we were looking at
those computers on on handlebars being
treated like the old Iron Man Himax
watches right they'd started they'd stop
it and they delete so for us it was just
an opportunity to go narrow and focused
know who we were talking to as an
audience but always with the strategy if
you go look at our earliest business
plans if we could get cyclists right
could we ultimately serve this global
community of athletes was there ever a
sense that maybe you should go after
running first because that's seen that's
a much bigger more democratic community
yeah we definitely debated that in the
beginning but if you think about where
where runners were in 2007-2008 as we're
starting it this is starting to take
shape GPS was not readily available in
the phones not certainly not with
sense of like longer battery life so
you're looking at some piece of hardware
you're gonna have to buy huh and runners
don't love to spend money they'd love to
buy their shoes and their their shorts
and that's it and the cyclists are
spending on power meters yes this
ridiculous is it here goes a cyclist
there was another twenty thousand dollar
bike and you know with all its
accessories and so I think it really was
just looking at where the where the
adoption of the technology that drives
what that makes Strava Strava is that
you need to you need to be able to
capture that workout in a way that
allows the magic to come to life and
that's GPS so we waited runners caught
on use now you you see that right on the
starting line of every half marathon ten
10k and almost everyone's starting their
watch or they're carrying their phone
with them yeah the bike is like this
perfect machine for data mining where
you can just extract so much information
and before the the seamlessness of the
technology that we're so used to today
it was pretty wonky you know just really
kind of on the horizon before you guys
you know launched this thing where you
could get this data but you know I
remember like trying to jerry-rig the
devices and connect them to my computer
and I was using I was exploring all
different kinds of platforms like at one
moment when I was getting really into
the data I was using gold and cheetah
and you have to be like a PhD to
understand those graphs yeah you know
that you could just spend hours like
getting into the nitty-gritty of all of
that but to find a way to take the best
of what something like that has to offer
and and make it palatable and accessible
to you know the avid but not you know
completely geeked out athlete is is no
small feat yeah I know
if we go back to where the original idea
for Strava came from it was even more
than a decade before can you imagine
what it would have been like which we
had this idea back in the 90s we like I
like to say we met last century we wrote
on the crew team together yeah we
graduated from the team and kind of lost
them lost connection to that sense of
camaraderie and that's what we wanted to
get back right away but in 1995-96
their GPS was even further away from
what you're talking about right the
sense of like what can you get out of
out of that like collecting all the data
and making it come to life in some way
so by the time we're rolling forward
into into you know the 21st century and
we're looking at what you know the
devices that are out there they're now
being adopted by cyclists we were like
oh that's us now that the time is right
yeah we actually have something to work
with and I think we're gonna see that
continue I don't think we're done yet
seeing in terms of seeing what kind of
yeah well this you know we can quantify
it self movement just continues to you
know explode like a mushroom cloud but I
mean timing was perfect for you guys you
were right at the epicenter of when GPS
technology became you know readily
available and the seamlessness of you
know mobile then coming online like
really seemed to work perfectly with you
know what you're trying to build the
earliest days you had to have a Garmin
device yeah you had to plug it into your
computer and you trust me I no idea yeah
we bought we still have a funny looking
the other day I think we spent something
like fifty two thousand dollars with
Costco just to buy all the Garmin 350 s
that they had on stock in order to give
them away to our friends so we remember
those days but you're right we caught a
fascinating wave where that technology
between battery life and GPS sensitivity
in the smart phones really turn the
corner right yeah you'd have to plug
your device in and whether or not you
can actually get the file to upload
properly was anybody's guess there's
still some issues with that you know
like some of these watches just don't
quite have the seamlessness that I think
they should at this point but when the
mobile technology became you know so
profligate and the battery life like you
said you could just use the app on the
phone itself to track it you didn't even
need one of these devices correct and we
see that's a really big area for for us
in terms of getting new athletes to come
on to the platform start using Strothers
that they already have the device in
their pocket now to get started all that
to do is download straw the downloads
for free you get started you have the
experience of connecting to a community
you knew is out there we just did not
and then a pretty common path is you go
from there to wanting more and then you
start to thinking well what else can I
do well there's this watch that looks
like it'd be the perfect thing for me
for what I do or there's this device
that would add to my experience and so
that upgrade path to to the device
experience right it's definitely we see
the lots of people do that and not
having to plug your watch in now anymore
for it to just work your Bluetooth yeah
seamless is huge well my own back there
like my own personal history with Strava
so it was my friend Stu bone who was a
cycling buddy of mine who's a longtime
friend of straw but you guys yeah we're
smiling like yeah that's that really if
you know Stu bone you're part of that
like the early gray so he was the guy
cuz he would be like you gotta get on
Strava I know like I know that he knew
you guys and I was riding with him quite
a bit in fact that was back when Stu was
living out of an Airstream if you know
Stu I don't know about this chapter of
his life but he would come here and he
would park his Airstream here for you
know a weekend or a week or a month and
kind of like live with us and I would
ride with him quite a bit so he's the
one who were initially tipped me on to
Strava and I got on it and again this
was back when it was just hardcore
cyclists and I was training at that time
mostly by myself but on and off with a
couple of the riders around here been
boström Eric Bostrom
occasionally with Dave Zabriskie and
like Tim Johnson was around here and
when segments became a thing it was kind
of amazing how quickly it just became
this communal competition to knock off
these K OMS and these guys would go at
it I remember there was an early outside
magazine story where it was Ben and Dave
and a couple of those other guys we're
always vying to get the kom on latigo
which is one of the great climbs around
here and I'm not nearly you know the
elite athlete that those guys are like I
can't you know I can't even stay in
there tailwind but I would find myself
out on the climbs and even when my coach
would give me a certain workout like
okay you got to stay in zone to cap that
heart rate and you know 130 or whatever
every time I hit a climb in the back of
my mind I'm like how's this gonna look
on Strava and I would just play games
with me and I was so focused on these
very specific ray
is that I was training for and being as
adherent as I could to my coaches
program that I had to then get off
Strava because it was screwing with me
too much and I would I would just always
go over my limit all the time because I
was so caught up in my ego and how this
would look and it wasn't until I turned
fifty two years ago and I hadn't raced
for a number of years and I decided I
want to do this race so tillow the
swimrun World Championships and I
thought this is a great opportunity to
share the whole process of preparing for
a race like this over our course of a
year so I got back on Strava after
taking an extended hiatus and just
decided like I'm gonna I'm gonna show
everybody what it's like to be 50 and
train for a race like this I'm gonna
share it every single workout on Strava
you know the lows the highs everything
and using that in conjunction with
Instagram specifically Instagram stories
was a really beautiful experience for me
but also for you know this growing
community of people I was amazed that
anybody would be interested but it was
really cool and it was so supportive and
it really held me accountable and put a
lot of wind in my sails and I just loved
every aspect of that and I've just been
using it ever since for every single
workout so thank you for that thank you
thank ya and I remember those early days
this seems like it's changed but you
know what's so great is that you can
follow these elite athletes that you
Revere and respect and admire and you
can like see what they're doing like
everyone from Kilian Jornet
Lance Armstrong and all you know Taylor
Finney all these amazing people and in
the early days sometimes they would mask
their power debt you know like they
didn't want everyone to know exactly
what was going on but that seems to that
veil seems to be lifted and now people
feel pretty free into sharing everything
knowing like listen I can show you this
but you're not gonna actually go do it
or whatever I mean maybe some of the
elite Tour de France guys but for the
most part there seems to be an openness
to sharing that in the early days people
were private about it or you know and
that seemed to have let go is is that
something you guys have noticed as well
absolutely yeah there's I think maybe a
sense of its the data those kinds of
aspects
the data or maybe a little less precious
it's not that's not really where the
yeah the secret is anymore largely
everyone's got their own way of training
and they think it's the right way for
them and otherwise I'd be doing
something differently so it is the power
is the power like that's that's what it
is and so I think when when you look at
something like the peloton and the Tour
de France it's what what we hear from
from the folks who are uploading Straub
is like well you know there's there's
there's the GCS out there they're
battling it out for for the trophy but
we're back here just trying to have a
really great event and Strava makes that
come to life for us for us Strava is the
event and we like that that aspect that
we can we can still feel really great
about the day because we battled it out
for the kom and that climb or we we got
to compare something around each other
because we're not the ones who are going
to be hitting the headlines in the
papers and so that aspect of it does
bring back sort of what's travas at the
core it's a sense of friendly
competition and camaraderie through
seeing what you're capable of and when
you describe your own story about maybe
finding that that was a little too
intense and then stepping away for a
while and coming back and then realizing
there's this whole other other side of
struggle that actually has nothing to do
with being at the top of the leaderboard
it's about telling your story as an
athlete the richness of the experience
and with the whether it's with photos or
it's how you title your activity or it's
the comments that you add to it they
bring it to life and people find that
extremely motivating and that part of it
that's what makes it rich for ya the
people following you yeah you can create
your own challenges around it using the
platform as a vehicle like you like what
Phil Gaiman is doing with you know
getting all over the world worlds
without yeah yeah I know I've had him on
the show talking about that - you know
all the Strava art that people are doing
proposing to you know their partners
using Strava art and my favorite my most
recent favorite is what Ricky Gates did
in San Francisco like running every
Street yeah yeah she's incredibly proud
yeah well I think he was working with
our team to try to make it come to life
so we had a little uh little extra
little extra secret computing there
going on but when I think about sort of
the platform is actually pretty simple
the only way you can contribute
something is by largely by uploading
activity we do allow you to you can you
can create a a verbal post as well but
the predominant motive of contributing
something is pretty constrained go do
something outside right or indoors
Estrada's for every sport indoor outdoor
in and we want want people to know that
that that's it's really we want to be
before anyway you want to be active and
sweat that's what we're for but that's
the way you participate on the platform
and so that that aspect of it is by
constraining in that way I think it
turns the creativity's now how do I use
this to be as creative as possible given
what I'm doing or discover that
something that's really new that I have
never done before that's in my backyard
because I see someone else doing it yeah
and so when I see that every street in
San Francisco I was like wow I bet I
could do like maybe that corner of it
right here right in my backyard that'd
be yeah yeah well with all the
discussions around I mean these ultra
races just get longer and longer and
crazier and crazier and then here's
Ricky who's just like look just use your
backyard you can create your own
incredible experience like to end and at
the same time connect with your
community in a really tactile way mmm
which is pretty cool
well you guys have had a really amazing
entrepreneurial journey to this point so
I'm interested in that story like let's
let's take it back to the Cambridge days
gamers days I know I'm the youngster
here yeah so yeah you're right we met
back in 1988 so as Michael said last
century I grew up in Reno Nevada and
ended up I was recruited to run at
Harvard mm-hmm I got a little lucky once
I got out there I was recruited by the
crew coaches and made that transition
and that's where I met Michael right in
that boathouse so you went to Harvard in
86 not exactly 86 right yeah I graduate
he's exactly Greg from High School in 86
I started to fall of 86 right and went
in as a runner and then what happened so
I went in ironically that fall I had
stress fractures so I wasn't able to run
and a very long story short got
introduced to somebody who was doing the
sort of what we call the freshmen
program this is now my sophomore year
in the crew program and went down to the
boathouse to see what it was all about
and happened to run into the varsity
coach at the time and gentleman aim in
Charlie but who still runs the whole
program today almost 30 years later and
he said what's your background
looked at me and you know kind of a tall
skinny kid with some big lungs and said
uh huh why are you here and I said yeah
I'm supposed to be in track and
cross-country but I've been injured and
you said well why don't you try this
thing called rowing and yeah one thing
led to another
mm-hmm my degree today should say crew
cuz that's where I spend right the rest
of my time well I was I was almost your
classmate I was I graduated high school
in 85 and almost went to Harvard yeah to
swim
actually for jobber now yeah but there's
something about that transition from
like running or swimming into crew it
seems to be like a natural you know
people who know how to suffer you know I
think that's right and growing is really
a highly individual sport at one level
you train as hard as you can to make the
best boat you can get into the first
both second boat and then as a team you
you try as hard as possible to beat the
other teams boat you know in that same
category and that was one thing that I
that really resonated with me is just
that an ability to - I played played
soccer growing up I've been on the
sailing team tennis different things
where they were there is this aspect of
you know just the combination of team
and individual and I found rowing to be
this great great sport for for being as
intense as possible and it into the
individual level and then and then being
as intense as possible as a group right
at the same time and my experience was
similar marks except I didn't have the I
didn't know what I had inside me at the
time when I when I started I had done
some running and done you know done some
sports like soccer or basketball but had
never found myself I never thought of
myself as an athlete so walking into the
boathouse what first drew me in was just
the sense of camaraderie that was there
and that sense that the people
were showing up never having rode before
also we're willing to give it a try and
I I thought so do so am i I'm willing to
give it a try I'm willing to see what
this is like after two or three weeks I
can I can decide then whether it's for
me or not I'd say by the third day I was
completely hooked this idea of showing
up getting in a boat getting out and
onto the onto the river all the other
cares in your life fade away for an hour
an hour and a half two hours and you're
just with that those group of people and
that that experiences is something you
share with those individuals that was
really powerful for me yeah it's a
manova difference between cycling
swimming or running is that you have to
work as a unit there's a real teamwork
aspect to it that you don't find another
endurance sports it's huge
yeah so you were a couple years since
all right we we span here I'm started
college in 1984 so when I meet my met
mark I was a senior he was a sophomore
but I stuck around in Cambridge for a
couple years after graduating and worked
in a job that allowed me to to help
coach the freshman program at Harvard
and so Mark and I would interact at the
boathouse and just became really good
friends before we both left Cambridge in
in 1990 and that aspect of it also is
like we never rode in the same boat
together
so though we've we've been business
partners now and friends for for over 30
years that experience was really unique
to each of us in the sense of what we
experienced in the boathouse and so that
says something about how common that the
commonality between the experiences we
weren't actually in the same boat we
weren't we weren't really on the same
team overlapping he was on the freshman
program when I was when I was a senior
so weren't even coached at the same time
by the same coach so but yet we come
away from it with the same experiences
the same sense of talking about it from
from what its shaped for us and what it
what it ultimately led to and in terms
of Stratis creation right
so Michael what was it that you saw in
marker or vice versa like why why why
did you guys bond like what you know
what is the genesis of this lifelong
relationship that you guys have
okay I can actually point to one
specific day where this is now fall of
89 I think mark you were you were
injured or okay remember what you
couldn't row against Yale and Princeton
which white peas it's called
Harvard Yale Princeton race it's a
three-way regatta where just before the
end of the season this year the race was
down in in Princeton in New Jersey and
so I said mark let's the car let's drive
down there see the race and you know we
hop in my I had two Jeep CJ five with a
soft top and it was pouring rain and
probably freezing colas remember just
being so incredibly cold but drove all
the way down into Jersey watch the watch
the regatta
what's the races and then drove back
same day and that was that was really
formed out I think in terms of our
friendship we we probably had it spent
more time in that car that day than we
had spent together previous to that and
I came away from that just but also just
recognizing how important was it was for
both of us to get down there and watch
the race and then and then just just
that sense of realizing I've found
somebody who I was really compatible
with a few more yeah yeah it's it's hard
this guide unless you've been there
having been a varsity athlete and now
you know this for the I mean the esprit
de corps inside that boathouse and where
I was fortunate was to have not only
Michael but a handful of his classmates
who were two years older who really took
me under their wing because I was a
novice in that boathouse i'm not held an
or before and so forth and so to start
with that friendship and experienced
that experie de corn but part of it is
just it's the trash-talking it's the
it's the competitions it's all those
things that you just end up constantly
obsessing over right that's what I say
my degree should say crew cuz it that is
where I spent my time went away and
physically and so for us the challenge
was we graduated and poof that sort of
disappeared so in many ways I think the
friendship was born one out of just a
necessity to still want to hold on to
this this great thing that we had and
this group of friends and and Michael
was the closest that I had there to that
I think the other thing too about the
two of us is that there's a there's a
really great yin and yang
I mean he's underplaying he went off and
got his PhD in economics yeah and you
know it's just an amazing person from
how he thinks and and the way he applies
you know looks at problems and implies
solutions to them and and I'm not that I
was art history I was coming things and
I much more sort of maybe intuitive or
sort of I'm not sure how to describe it
it's just not smart the way that
Michael's not an educated way but that
yin and yang has worked well for us
whether it's in a friendship whether
it's in other kinds of relationships or
and has it proved out pretty well in
businesses yeah and in this stroke of
fortune you guys after Harvard you both
end up like in Palo Alto right at the
same time you're teaching at Stanford
yeah teaching economics right so Marx
mentioned I decided to get a PhD in
economics not after what that was after
working for a couple years and my first
job out of grad school was on the
faculty at Stanford I arrived in the
summer of 1994 and you know for any of
your listeners who are you know over the
age of maybe 45 they understand what
that what that means is like the world
just shifted all of a sudden the
internet was born the consumer Internet
was was something that I won email
before I graduated with my PhD and then
I arrived at Stanford and the IT person
in the department comes in and says I'm
gonna install a browser on your computer
now and right I said what's a browser
you know and he said you haven't heard
of most of mosaic and like I said that
was this free software you could get
that would surf the web so I had no idea
what you're talking about
and then Mark was in Palo Alto working
at a venture capital firm and they had
you know if they had internet at all it
was dial-up internet and I was at a
university which had great bandwidth you
know for the time so he would come to my
office I think partly because you know
just like how do you even access this
thing called Internet if you don't have
an internet connection you didn't have
it at home for sure and so he'd come in
my office and we would spend some time
just like trying to explore what is this
thing what is going on he
and that that led those those early days
of just interacting around this
completely new world led to some talking
about so what could we do with this what
would what would hit marks job deja was
calling up entrepreneurs and and talking
to them out their ideas and what they
had what they had started and and I was
and not that I had it was a free time
but I was also in this space where as an
academic your your your kind of job is
to is to think and be creative a lot
like an entrepreneur and and I was
trying to understand what this you know
what this whole new world was as well so
that's where some of the early the early
thinking around well could we really
create a company doing something with
the Internet you know what would that be
what and actually the first thing we
thought of was how do you create the
virtual team I'm gonna make how do you
make it possible to interact around your
workouts with people and Mark you were
at Ta associates right yeah I
interviewed for a job there did you
really didn't get it yeah I don't know
how I got mine I just remember when I
read that nearby I was like oh my
goodness TAC I remember there was a guy
who worked there his name escapes me
Sean Murphy oh I know Sean Murphy he was
big swimmer yeah yeah yeah Sean Sean is
actually the reason that I got an
interview there I think Sean was a
teammate of mine okay I don't but I
remember that guy who I don't know he
was a partner there but the person who I
interviewed with wore this full-length
leather coat and he just looked very
slick and cool just look like like this
seemed like a cool place to work and it
was an office like right off University
Avenue right yeah I remember that and I
also remember summer of 94 and Palo Alto
was world cup did you move there right
that out sanity's crazy I was trying to
study for the bar there when that was
going on that did not go well
no Williams came to town yeah but ta was
to my recollection kind of one of the
early venture funds before venture
capital became like a thing like they
were they were like an early mover in
that space you know they were they'd
been around the Furman runs to 68 so
better in a long time Boston based kinda
blue blue
firm but you know they're a unique
quality was that they had a very
specific kind of company that they would
target which is why I had a job as a kid
coming out of college they looked for
bootstrapped entrepreneur early on
profitable growing businesses so rather
than reading business plans and so forth
they actually had folks like me calling
entrepreneurs all day long uh-huh all
over the country I'd walk in on a Monday
morning and have a stack of newspapers
on my desk from Denver and Dubuque Iowa
and Arizona and so forth and I look for
walnuts I've looked to see who's hiring
in that city and then I'd call on them
so for me it was just this great he's a
little bit like going to business school
I got paid to talk to entrepreneurs all
day long and and I caught the bug yeah
it gave you that that sense of
possibility oh it was it was so many
great lessons great mentors they're both
on the entrepreneur side and the
investment side but ultimately new
investing wasn't for me and so I I left
I left in late 95 to go do something
actually probably remember I went to go
work at Metro support if you remember
the old running store yes I went from
working at T Associates in venture
capital to selling shoes for $8 an hour
but with the idea being that you were
gonna figure out some kind of
entrepreneurial play I needed a job that
I wouldn't feel guilty working on my you
know moonlighting with my own thing ta
was a TA was an intense job and it
required your time attention I could go
work at Metro support for six hours or
whatever it was hanging out with some
good friends and still have great
friends from my metros four days but
once I punched the clock I could go work
on my startup right that was gonna be
and so how did you guys come up with
this first company that you started so
Michael hit the nail and had our very
first business plan was called Kanna
sports Khanna was the name of my dog at
the time and it was the virtual locker
room we really did want to go recreate
this experience we had a new a boathouse
but use the internet to do it so in many
ways it was Strava 1.0 and this was in
1995 we still have the business plan
today the irony was a very long story
short in trying to figure out how to
make that a business we got introduced
to a bunch of other sporting goods
companies that were trying to build
their own Internet
and we identified a different problem
which was talking to their customers via
email which was something totally
foreign and new to these companies taken
Nike or a trek by Sakura
Mizuno they all had web presence but
they never built any infrastructure to
deal directly with the consumer they had
retailers do it so for the first time
they were getting these emails into
people from from consumers ask him about
sizes and shapes and colors and so forth
and they were just letting those emails
drop and Michael and I look at that
input well that doesn't make any sense
why do you spend millions of dollars
building a website and not want to talk
to your customer at the same time our
virtual locker room had some fundamental
business model challenges we weren't
quite sure how we were actually going to
make money at it and so we evolved the
business and that became Connick
communications doing customer email
solutions for we thought would just be
the sporting into industry but it turned
out that anybody putting up a website
and trying to build a real business
online needed these kinds of solutions
right so it's so essentially moving
customer service from the phone to
digital that's correct yeah but you're
you're forgetting like the like the key
part here is which we take this idea for
kind of sports like do we go and talk to
some companies making websites and
saying hey could you build this for us
what we want is a place where people can
come on to the site and interact with
each other around their data around
around their experience of being out
there riding their bikes and running and
and you know talk to each other kind of
interact and and like like a network you
know like a social network and they're
like dude that's nuts nobody would do
that it's crazy and all we have is HTML
we can't build this in like once you
call yourself a real problem and then
they you know unfortunately they turn us
away from building yeah I'm sure a lot
of people say they had the idea for the
first social network on on the internet
but this is 1995 and we're talking about
essentially the same things you
described about what what you saw in
Strava when you got on there that was in
the original idea because that's really
what we had experienced on the crew team
it wasn't just about you know the the
actual activities we did the workouts we
did it was about that sense of going
down and seeing what the workout was for
the day and talking with your your
your your teammates about the workout
that's gonna be hard or like I'm really
glad we're doing that today
and then doing it and then talking about
it afterwards it was like the before
during and after and that's what we
wanted to represent in some meaningful
way through through through our Cana
Sports Network and that that getting
talked out of it because it just the
technology was so far away was the best
thing that ever happened honestly wid we
started this in 95 it would have failed
no one would have wanted to use this
there's no way to get data in yeah that
technology will ensure no no no
definitely not but that sense of like
not nobody wants to interact on the
internet with each other that you go go
go build this piece of boring software
for companies to help them handle their
emails from customers that's what we
ended up doing so but kana becomes a
huge thing right comes this massive
company such a great you talked earlier
about so much of his timing and catching
certain ways the quantified self and
social networks what happened with
Strama the same thing was true with with
kana we were very fortunate this
combination of both the excitement to go
build a business online where we saw
both new companies the eBay's and the
Yahoo's doing but also very traditional
companies a Ford Motor Company's and it
chase me everybody was trying to figure
out how they were going to build a
presence on the internet and
simultaneously you had this fascination
with customer service CRM was the
acronym that everybody loved to use
customer relationship management and so
we just happen to be sort of at the apex
of those waves that were crashing and I
love to look back on I mean we got to do
in four or five years what many people
try to do in a lifetime of a career we
went from two guys and a dog hanging out
in a very small little shack just just
off the Stanford campus there to you
know when I left in summer of 2000 we
were 1200 people and a couple hundred
million in revenue and publicly traded
right yeah I was it was it was a really
fun experience
cut the bug early early IPO you know
success right internet like not 1.0 but
pre 2.0 I guess yeah yeah and then in
the wake of that massive success Manoj
Ekta a little bit but the technology is
caught up enough where suddenly the
original idea behind kana seems like it
might be
possible - yes there's a there's a
period in there between 2000 and 2006
2007 where there's a whole bunch of
other things going on in our life
probably not necessarily related to the
technology evolution that you're
describing but just sort of what it is -
to be living and raising families and
all the all the ins and outs that come
with that but we were always in touch we
were always even though Michael now
moved to the East Coast was raising his
family in the East Coast and I was still
in California constantly brainstorming
ideas frankly that both of us were
sitting on way too many boards and you
know I always joke it's a bit like
eating junk food it's just taste really
good in the moment but not terribly
satisfying long term and so you're right
we got to that 2006-2007 timeframe and
said or too young with there's got to be
something we can go do again and that's
when we dust it off
aha the plan looked at other things as
well but ultimately it was Strava that
surfaced as something that we really
wanted to try build right and GPS
technology is kind of matured with
certain points where it seems like this
is possible mm-hmm yeah I would even say
that we we launched Strava into a pretty
crowded space already of companies
trying to do something very similar
record your work out and get some
feedback from that experience that data
you're collecting and what they you know
what what was unique about Strava I'd
say we recognized that we wanted to
build that social element that sense of
community was front and center in the
experience as opposed to something that
you might double in once in a while it
was really the way you you you use
Strava was to connect to a community and
I think the other part that was it was a
piece of magic that we were fortunate
enough to meet individual named Davis
Kitchell in living just across the river
from Hanover New Hampshire where I was
based I was living in New Hanover New
Hampshire and he lives in Norwich across
the river and my 20th sorry on December
20th 2006 I turned 40 I am that's the
first time I met I met Davey and he's
telling telling me about
he's been dabbling with how can you use
GPS to
to track in his case he was interested
in tracking rowing workouts he was a
rower in college went to Dartmouth and
he was thinking this might also be
something that could be used for for
cycling for comparing on rowing is
you're growing on a river you don't know
whether you went faster today on the
same stretch than yesterday he's like
okay you use GPS to sort of compare your
times on the same stretch of river or
the same stretch of road what he's
describing essentially is the is what's
now known as Strava segments so he's
he's the inventor of segments and holds
the patents for it and well Strava holds
it and his name and but but that fortune
of being able to meet the person who
held part of the magic of what made
Strether come to life gave it a
heartbeat and that's that's I think
where you can you can make all the plans
and do all the thinking but sometimes
you just have to have a spark that comes
from yeah from the universe and I mean
is the real differentiator from the
get-go right because at the time I mean
who were the players like Nike+ were
they they were around definitely right
and what else was it like Matt my ride
yeah that kind of stuff right which were
all I kind of wonky some of them are
still around to Nike+ is still doing its
thing but you were able to very quickly
outpace all of these took a different
path by being very focused on that
cycling community early I think we were
able to meet some needs that just
weren't addressed in the marketplace and
that delivered on that almost that
addiction or at least that yeah
fanaticism that we've seen in our
community and it feels like I'm
interested in your experience with this
but it feels like it was a word-of-mouth
thing like if you're a cyclist and
you're in the like I found out from Stu
and you know and I you know it was just
it was just something that we that cos
cyclists talk they ride in packs you
know for the most part there is a
community aspect of it that probably
isn't too dissimilar from from rowing
even though it's individuated but it was
just the chatting amongst other riders
that kind of made it catch fire that's
right I think that's where I tell people
that Strava really spreads by word of
mouth we have lots of great people in
our marketing team and our growth team
helping us grow faster but what they're
trying to accentuate is how can we help
people tell their
story about Strava to their friends and
it is something when that comes to life
for you the first time you second time
you use Java you come you say well this
is really unique and different I'm gonna
tell people I know who might like this
and that's that's a really powerful tool
powerful way to way to grow I think
that's that's really where the early
version of Strava the earliest versions
of straw but we didn't necessarily know
that that's what we had stumbled upon or
that we that we had had brought to life
but once we started to hear the stories
people will tell us and how how in sense
it kept them coming back for more once
you you connect with others and you have
that experience of being in that
community and whether you're comparing
your times on on Strava segments or
you're simply just seeing people's
photos and getting motivated through
that you want to do it more you want to
get out there and and do your own
activities and and you want to see
perceive that sense of motivation from
others and then you see what other
people are doing and then you get that
motivation again so it's a flywheel
effect yeah and then you tell your
friends more you talk to you talk to
people about what you use and if Strava
isn't meaningful part of your athletic
life you're gonna tell your friends
about it I remember I think the first
sense that I had that this thing was
really blowing up was maybe late 2008 or
sometime in 2009 perhaps there was this
thing called the Santa Monica Mountains
challenge out here where the idea was
over a 30 day period you ride every
climb in this I guess it's a mountain
range sort of a mountain range out here
and I don't know how many climbs are
worth maybe 20 or 30 or something like
that and whoever had the fastest
cumulative time over all of these climbs
would win at the end of this 30 day
period and every hardcore rider in this
area was after it and it got so
competitive that to my memory some of
the riders would were waiting like they
would track and see what the times were
they wait till the very last day to go
out and do it so that they would clip it
and then there wouldn't be time enough
for somebody else to go and grab it and
I was like wow these people are spending
in an unbelievable amount of time and
energy on this challenge that just I
don't know who created it but it was
community created I suspect and then
there was a party when this whole thing
completed at
frança bikes which is a local bike
company out here that I've worked with
over the years and all the riders came
it was a big party and I was like wow
this is like really something and it
really did
merge the digital with the analog by
bringing people together in a real world
setting which was really cool we've got
a fun it's not story that we tell often
but if you go back to our earliest Davy
Kitchell Michael mentioned our honor the
inventor of segments he created
something we called the Green Machine it
was a very first website that we had
this was summer of 2008 and we put ten
people on the system so that's it we had
ten customers we had five on the west
coast and five on the East Coast and we
just wanted to see what would happen if
we used a 30-day period happened to be
during the the tour during the Tour de
France in July of 2008 let's let those
five from each coast sort of compete
against each other and create some
virtual competition just the way you're
describing the Santa Monica challenge
and the behavior we watched over that 30
day period was absolutely what sold us
in the fact that there's a business here
the trash-talking the competitive
strategy that would go into sort of as
you were just describing sort of okay we
need to pick a specific course to try to
hit a 5k time or whatever the Preem was
for the day we'd give certain awards
each day but it really opened our eyes
to a how social cycling actually is and
just the way in which these workouts
when they're brought together or sort of
you're allowed to compare and contrast
them brings a whole other motivation to
the story and you could have people in
totally different parts of the world
having a common experience through
stralla and so that's what we see today
of you know 38 million athletes around
the world from 165 plus countries and
the level of interactivity I think it's
something like over three billion kudos
a year alright or given between these
athletes so you do the math you're like
wow these people are really interacting
around around around being an app being
at being active and that that's what
that was we saw in the first you know
that first summer we heard stories like
you know some of the people now joined
our company they Mark Shaw and Chris
Donahue were part of the original 10 and
they decided hey if you guys are really
because they were part of the kana
suffer days they were employees seven
and eight I think at Cana so they knew
us really well and we've worked together
and now for many many years they said if
you guys are serious about this man
because yesterday I called in sick to
work so I could go out and ride my bike
I was like oh wow we are changing
behavior that's great yeah yeah yeah
we're onto that I have found something
really unique
yeah the positive encouragement but also
that kind of negative pressure like if I
don't show up and post like people are
gonna know and I'm gonna catch win for
it but it even though the earliest sort
of thinking around this is we're trying
to get people you know to put down their
their phone close their screen and get
out there and be active right so yes you
do come back to those those those
surfaces to go and have the experience
but you can't really participate there
if you haven't been out there right
doing doing whatever it is that makes
you that fuels you right so that
test-case experience was that when it
like locked in for you like hey this is
real like we're gonna be able to scale
this and create a business around it
yeah I don't I think if we're honest we
wouldn't have predicted this size and
scope and scale that we see today
Michael and I were we probably would
have been happy if 10 or 20 of us we're
having a great time it was keeping us
active again that was the mission the
mission in many respects is how do I
rebuild that team that I had back in the
late 80s and early 90s how do I stay
motivated and you know Michael I've been
very fortunate our life it wasn't like
we needed to go build another public
company it was we know how important
being active is to us to our families to
everybody else how do we keep that
motivation so it was enough for us to
say let's invest in Strava
and if Strava ends up supporting ten
employees and a few hundred rabid
cycling fans great you fast forward 10
years it took on a life of its own right
I couldn't be more happy but yeah it's
been a crazy road so 38 million people
some odd people on the platform now
you're onboarding like like a million
people a month or something like that
yeah that's crazy
and you self-funded this thing for the
first couple years right we did and the
thinking there was just well number one
we we wanted to see what this would what
form this would take and we'd been part
of plenty of examples of companies as
board members or investors where you
know you come in early not knowing where
it's gonna go and it doesn't go a place
where you you really wish you you really
wish you hadn't raised the money having
other people's money changes the
expectations around what success means
and so we could see this as Mark said
being being a an enterprise that was
much smaller in scope and scale than it
is today and we would been happy
individually so we didn't want to have
other people along for the ride until we
were sure what this was going to be
things did change I think some of the
factors were launching our first mobile
apps just exploded the growth that was
really we reached around the world with
through the app stores and got got a
sense of what this could be how big it
could be and then we looked at our our
own you know how concentrated do we want
our our assets into one company and so
we realized that that that to fuel the
growth of the company the best strategy
would be to go find like-minded
investors who shared our long-run vision
to come along and join us and as as two
guys who are two for two
like wildly successful with these two
companies what did you learn from the
experience of founding and building and
growing kana that informed how you want
it to structure Strava to you know sort
of position it for a long-term success
the lesson that I would point to was
this notion of taking risk on what looks
like too small market early so if you
think about kana we were email customer
service our first product did nothing
other than when you get an email into
your inbox as a customer service rep in
a company how can you respond we didn't
have the way for someone to actually
create an email in the in the Econo
system literally there had to be an
inbound message that you could send an
outbound response to it was very narrow
and very focused and we had lots of
investors who turned us down because
like guys you've built a feature not a
product but we had customers that were
hungry for that for that feature so you
fast forward to the Strama days
many ways the same thing applied which
was look we don't necessarily believe
that cycling is going to be the end-all
game that's not necessarily the mission
but if we can stay focused there and
really address the needs of that market
what happens is you then find yourself
as any leadership position it may be in
a leadership position of what looks like
still a small market but now you have a
voice and now you can begin to build off
that success and haha that gave us I
think the strength of conviction to then
open the platform to runners and and you
know ultimately to a wide spectrum of
athletes yeah I don't know that we would
have had the confidence had we not seen
it happen at Cana because Cana again
what started as customer email response
by the time we were going public
we had a expansive solution that solved
all kinds of marketing and customer
support needs but you had to grow into
it you couldn't do it from day one yeah
I think that's a really powerful lesson
for for anybody who's trying to you know
people that are online trying to build
an audience they're so worried about
growth and how many people are following
them and all of that rather than just
making sure that they're taking care of
the people who are already interested in
what they're doing and making sure those
people are happy bike being super
focused on that gives you a lot more
credibility I think and and and and an
insurance policy against you know growth
long term than anything else I think
that was super smart and I remember in
those early days when I would go out
running and it was like I don't think he
initially you could even upload a run
right yeah it was it was a ride trust me
lots of runs yeah but then when the time
was right you're like okay let's just
expand the aperture a teeny bit a teeny
bit more a teeny bit more and we took
grief
we took grief from our cycling community
only when we launched I think we've
opinionated bunch that crew from how
high your socks are to my gears whether
you're whether your sunglasses can go in
you know inside the helmet straps or
outside like there's a lot of commonly
held beliefs around these things and as
a result I mean in the early days we our
app we had a cycling up and a run
because we right he didn't think the
cyclist would would want to download an
app that was for everybody and likewise
for the runners there they're equally
opinionated sometimes so that was a
learning lesson to expand into running
didn't just mean making some small
changes in the user experience and an
athlete experience in the app it was
really building a whole new team of
people who were passionate about run
inside the company because you tell a
cyclist well make it for runners and
they're like well we can leave the miles
per hour can't we it's like no runners
don't think about miles per hour
anything about minutes per mile you got
to change that and they're like that's
it makes no sense but believe me it's a
it makes a huge difference when you have
people in in building this building the
product that that are passionate about
the sport so we had to build build
pretty much a separate team like that
could be really successful thinking
through the needs of the runner and then
convinced as Mark said convinced our our
core audience that we weren't selling
out right we were trying to build
something that they would ultimately
love and would help fuel their
motivation because they have friends who
run and they do some amazing things and
that's a that's a source of motivation
even if you're spending all of your time
on a bike was the calculus to go after
the elite Runner community first in the
sense that you wanted to go after the
hardcore cyclist first because running
is so much more democratic and that the
population is so much more kind of
diverse in terms of skill and acumen
I think the way we've always thought
about is let's build for the most
demanding athletes in the world if we
can you know I stress test it for them
yeah and it's not necessary but with the
acknowledgement that this needs to be
easy and simple enough that everybody
can use it's it's a it's a fine line I
always joke if Nike can figure out how
to build a $250 shoe that's worn by you
know the Olympic marathoner and yet I
have no problem walking the store and
buying it because I need that shoe as
well how do we do that as strong how do
we make sure that what we have is
provides the kinds of features and
services and so forth that someone who's
at the elite level will be driven
towards but at the end of the day the
way you describe some of the early other
solutions out there that were really
complex and hard to to read and sort of
navigate
this needs to be simple this needs to be
at the end of day we always used to say
it Strava if it's not fun and
entertaining we've missed the mark
because it's fundamentally what keeps us
motivated right but to innovate at the
highest level creates an aspirational
brand right that then everybody wants to
be a part of yeah we used to talk about
it in terms of if athletes are oriented
on a on a pyramid and the top part the
top third of the pyramid is this this
you know the persona that we're we're
inventing Strava for and the bottom of
people who maybe aren't really sure that
they want to be active at all they don't
wake up thinking how am I going to be
active today we were aiming for the top
because that would pull in the middle if
we aim for the for the big part in the
middle or the even you know it's like
some of our competitors did aim for the
person who doesn't doesn't even know
that they're gonna be active on a
regular basis we're never gonna get the
top third of the pyramid and we don't
create an aspirational brand that brings
everybody and eventually so is it was
starting at the top and eventually
hoping that that would bring up
everybody bring everybody into the
experience and anything that's that's
you know for most part that's that's
been the experience and it's come along
with some challenges for sure which is
one of the things we talk about is like
how do we how do we use the word athlete
when a lot of people who used to either
don't identify with that term they don't
they don't think of themselves as as
athletes and we define it as if you
sweat you're an athlete that's as simple
as that and so a lot of people say okay
I sweat I guess I straw but for me
that's try yeah and now I feel like the
the brand has transcended any of these
specific disciplines it's just it's just
like a it's like a the identification
that an athlete has with Strava seems to
be just what's the right word I'm
searching for it is an aspirational
brand like the the brand awareness
transcends cycling or running or
triathlon or anything like yeah I may
not call I wouldn't say it's a tattoo
brim but definitely a t-shirt brand
you'd want to wear astrov a t-shirt or
we used to sell those by the way that
was really pretty cool we should bring
it back why are you doing that yeah get
the swag out there
but you know you want to wear the
t-shirt or you want to once you're
you're in for a while and in the
experience and you've been using it for
a while like well this is the way I am
an athlete now this is a generational
brand like I can think about if I'm
gonna I'm not not just dabbling here I'm
gonna be here for for as long as I'm
active so I think that's that's also
another aspect that I think we were
shooting for and going back in the early
days when our experience had kind of
taught us something else on the you know
the on the negative side which is when
you when you think about sort of
successes being defined by either
liquidity or an exit and you are
building your company in with sort of
that is like that's the ultimate goal is
to return you know sort of return to
like a carefree life where you never
have to think about the company again
that's a that's not a great company
that's a that's a four-year stint
they're trying to win you know the gold
medal and when you have that experience
alright we did and we didn't want that
we wanted something we could see
ourselves involved in for decades and we
said 20 30 years we think we can be part
of building this brand and company and
experience and bringing it to as many
people as possible around the world and
you know so we're here 10 years in then
we're still our roles have have changed
and morphed over the years but we're
still here we're still building Strava
and excited to do so and I think that's
as you know as important as that's all
the all the positives we learned from
condos the negatives of just what
happens when you when you lose sight of
hate we're trying to build something
really great and let's keep doing it as
long as we possibly can have you had
suitors along the way who've come down
the pike offering to buy the company not
not at a number that would be yeah
interesting being cagey about that
itself at some point somebody well I
would imagine and will be thoughtful and
strategic and we we we take all calls
and and have great conversations with
lots of partners out there but Michael
hit the nail on the head we I'd look at
it this way you go back to Kanna we gave
everybody who joined Kanna to books they
got the art of war by Sun Tzu and they
got a book called built to last by Jim
Collins and it's a little bit of like
the yin and yang of
business and we had unfinished business
with comet we didn't do the built to
last
lots of great outcomes for investors for
employees for customers kind of still
used today out there it's a great piece
of software but it wasn't the
organization that we could hang our hats
on for four years you fast forward to
the summer 2006 Michael and I sat down
together in a little condo in Vail
Colorado to start brainstorming what's
our next business going to be and before
we even started started thinking about
our business we started thinking about
other businesses that we admired they
weren't the Kaunas of the world they
were they were the Patagonia's and the
oakley's or the virgins and and so forth
these great consumer brands that sort of
wish stood the test of time as you
describe sort of aspirational brands and
so that's that's been a mission from day
one here is Drive I don't know we've
always got it right we got plenty of
challenges but this is one where I'd
love to think that this far out lasts
either of us yeah and what we're doing
well the Oakley founder was a mentor of
yours early on right Jim Jannard ta days
yeah you know I was very what did you
learn from him oh my goodness he was
he's fascinating guy I mean some simple
things you know if you're gonna be an
entrepreneur you are going to live eat
and breathe your business 24/7 365 days
a year and don't expect to make any
money any time soon so you better love
what you do I don't know if anybody
knows his story but he started by
selling motorcycle handgrips out of a
Volkswagen van my
baja yeah he was dirt bikes and he saw
the problem with motorcycle goggles
coming in and so he developed a goggle
so it'd be the second thing is you know
again a very focused narrow approach to
how he went about his business yeah you
mean just just a great so much of it was
not necessarily a specific lesson but an
attitude just you you you grind and you
you you keep going and you you focus on
quality I think sometimes we get lost
and so can value it's very much sort of
up and to the right all the time how
fast are you growing and so forth I'd
like to think to describe oh we still
have this emphasis on just let's do a
right it may take us a little bit long
but let's build that into the system and
and I think at least the early days of
Oakley we're now going back to the you
know early 90s before yeah and his
company was bought but fantastic company
so you guys have run the gamut being in
Silicon Valley you know building two
companies and we're kind of in a in a
period right now where there's a there's
a backlash against Silicon Valley and
and you know a healthy suspect when it
comes to these social media platforms
you know it's all in the news and we all
know these stories well you know how do
you kind of look at your fellow you know
social network pioneers like what are
they doing wrong what are they doing
right like how can the community the
technology community do better to kind
of solve some of the toxicity problems
that we're seeing now well right so I
don't I don't know any of those you guys
get together personally and so I don't
want to speak about like what I think
they're not all in the clubhouse
together I think there's a sense you
know honestly I think there's an idea
that that you guys are doing that there
is like this cabal you never received
the invitation but I rather than talk
about what what you know they're doing
wrong I think what we're asking observe
as an observer of what we're maybe what
we're focused on is so we have we have
core values it's Java we call them the
stall the ABCs there's a there's a B and
there's three C's so the a is for
authenticity and B is for balance and
then there's camaraderie commitment and
craftsmanship and so but I'm gonna talk
about authenticity to answer this this
one because I think that's what that
says is linking what you say what you do
and what your customer experiences are
all have to be consistent if that's not
the case then you're not authentic and
your company's not authentic something
about their something in there is gone
awry and so at Strava we set out to
serve the athlete when day one when we
said we're gonna do this that summer of
2008 when we clearly had something that
people were resonating with we said
that's who that this is it this we've
found we found the the customer if you
will the person who we want to serve is
the person who wakes up every day saying
what am I gonna do to do to be active
today and so we wanted Strava to be
doing engaged in serving that person and
so we start any any idea that comes
along we we start with a question does
it serve the athlete if it doesn't we're
not gonna do it we're gonna say somebody
else can do that idea it's not not for
us it's not that's not part of the
Strava world and then we go on to other
questions like is it good for the
business or does it serve some other you
know purpose and but the starting point
is always does it serve the athletes so
I think that's where good businesses
have to have that that linkage that
authenticity and maybe that's where you
know if I if I do now look at outside
and some of the stories I've read just
again what I read in the papers it's I
question whether there is that link
between what the company says they're
there they're doing what they're
actually doing and then sort of you know
sort of how the customer if you will the
and the user is you know therefore
caught in the middle between the the
disparity between those two things yeah
rich it I go back an early statement
that Michael and I had was let's treat
Strava as though it's a very important
piece of gear for the cyclist it's got
to have high utility but that that's we
wanted our members to to refer to Strava
as though it was as important as those
new wheels that they just bought or
their helmet or there should whatever it
happened to be for their sport and by
thinking through that model you're then
in a place where as Michael refers to
this opportunity okay so now we're
serving yes we're very clear who our
customers if you look at our business
model today the predominance of our
revenue comes directly from from our
consumers they pay for summit which is
the the premium version I think we've
been fortunate in a sense that we've
been able to maintain sort of that
clarity in that authenticity he
described which then leads to another
important word which I don't I think at
least inside Strava we've tried to
maintain which is transparency we're
going to make mistakes some of the stuff
is is new we just could not have Ruby
the first technology there's no way we
could have predicted the ways in which
people would want to use Strava in the
ways that they have and so our ability
to be very transparent and understand
that and to adjust I think has been an
important part of sort of the growth for
our business and I would argue for any
of the others yeah the way that users
kind of take the platform and
make it their own and start to tell you
what it is is something that's out of
your control and I think the gestalt
like the pace of these things happen so
quickly that even the best intentioned
people it can spiral out of control and
you look at Twitter and what Jack Dorsey
is having to contend with right now like
these are really difficult problems and
I feel like he he's been doing a little
bit of a podcast to her lately
he's being really transparent about what
they're doing right and the challenges
they face and and what they haven't done
right and how difficult it is to try to
find solutions to these things or you
take you know you look at Zuckerberg in
the way ways in which the platform is
being co-opted for ulterior motives yeah
that's a different sticky wicket but you
guys have have really been able to
remain clear of those kind of toxic
forces because of the nature of I think
your user base which is very different
but you haven't you're not without your
controversy I mean you have this heatmap
thing like can you walk me through like
what happened with that there's a lot of
how much I can get right yeah so I mean
you took that's the only time I've ever
seen you guys take any kind of any kind
of heat you know it deservedly so
there's some things here and I'm just
interested in you know what happened
from your perspective so what you're
referring to a little over a year ago
there was a student who believed use out
of Australia who began putting up on
Twitter or very specific parts of our
map so when you refer that heat map
these are you know we have this global
map that shows all the public activities
that people have posted around the world
and you can you can focus in two very
specific areas anywhere in the world and
it's it's an amazing tool it's an
amazing thing to look at because you'll
see uploads in 190 countries today
you'll see uploads and on the South Pole
you'll see uploads and you'll see
uploads in places that are pretty
extreme for instance war zones and so
forth where there's military bases this
gentleman in Austria a young student was
posting on Twitter some of the areas
where he was identifying military
outlets and military bases where you
could see Strava uploads people were
working out on these bases
now I'll start by saying the good news
was we've actually worked closely with
certain governments and and military
organizations for years and so
thankfully there wasn't anything that
was being disclosed on Strava that
somehow was illegal or was putting
people in harm's way but there was a
perception out there that because we
weren't openly talking about the way in
which people were uploading that somehow
we were disclosing things we shouldn't
and that's where they opera where we
came because it just took on a life of
its own you started to see headlines
that Strava was outing military bases
and things like that so when maybe you
can probably talk to the things that
we've done to improve both our
communication on this and what it is to
post a public activity and so forth the
heatmap remains live we update it on a
very regular basis it's a valuable tool
we work closely again with military and
government to make sure that they're
working with their folks and and that
there's rules in place so that people
don't post and put anyone in harm's way
but it was a good lesson for us in terms
of the way which perception becomes
reality very quickly right yeah my
recollection was that military personnel
were uploading the Strava and they had
their privacy settings set public
basically so that anybody could see this
and if these individuals happen to be on
bases that were you know not publicly
known that that would create you know a
potential security risk correct although
I believe the military's been very good
at monitoring Strava and knows we're
they we're not doing that beforehand
like I like people were doing this
without tweaking their privacy settings
or this is where and you may have we
were told because we in in the wake of
this the media story here in the native
media event we we had lots of outreach
to military not just the US but other
countries as well and they assured us
you you haven't strop has not revealed
anything that the world didn't already
know this is these aren't truly
clandestine bases that no one ever knew
existed but the fact is that that this
is a this isn't a Strava problem it's a
military problem we need to
ensure that whether it's Strava or
twitter or any other social media that
that are our soldiers are our active
personnel in these places they need to
be conscious of what is public when
they're posting to social media and and
that goes across the board a lot of
different things if you're cheating and
you have your Geo locator on its gonna
do the same thing sure so it's there is
there's a way in which we play into this
though which is you know we what we did
in the wake of this was to say like ok
so how do we assess how to make it more
likely that someone's going to choose to
do the right thing with their privacy
settings right so we have taken a lot of
steps to try to make it easier to
understand this private your your how
you set your privacy affects your user
experience do you want do you want to
show up and leader birds or don't you
well that affects have like what kind of
experience you're gonna have in Strava
do you want to be able to be found in a
search to be able to have your friends
find you and be able to follow you and
give you kudos and comments and all
those things are hard to understand when
you're first joining strata and you
don't really understand what they mean
and so what we've done we've taken steps
to try to make that more clear so that
people will choose the rights that are
the privacy settings that are right for
them in their situation I think that's
that's the part that we we take you know
I think at this point really good pride
in in the way in which we've built a
much more consistent and unified flow
and how you set your privacy settings
because it's super important that people
understand what they're getting
themselves into and depending on who and
where they are so today we're Strava x'
Strava came out of that I think with
some really important learnings and
lessons and it triggered some changes
and I think we also the world also
hopefully at this point understands that
we didn't out any any soldiers in any
secret places that they that's good to
know because I actually didn't know that
I thought there was some outing some
some inadvertent outing there years
earlier we'd actually worked with NATO
in a situation that was more like that
where they just said we're uncomfortable
with what's being disclosed and we work
with them to in their their soldiers and
places in the field so that that didn't
show up on the yeah
yeah I mean I think you know I I see you
guys as as two people who had privacy
considerations very early on because
from I don't know if it was inverse
one but pretty early on you could you
could mask your house and like create a
perimeter so that people can figure out
where you lived I mean that was very
early in the app right yeah this goes
back to this notion of first and
foremost high utility let's make sure
we're serving the athlete and so you're
exactly right we we thought through lots
of different privacy scenarios and how
could we create tools Michael's right I
think if anything what came out of this
heat map was how do we simplify that and
the challenge is it really is an art
Michael is almost downplaying the it's
really fun to listen to our community
because they'll often want both they
want extreme privacy but they want to be
on that leader board they want to know
how they did against their friends and
it's like you you really can't have it
both ways if you're going to we can give
you the privacy or you can compete and
have fun with your friends but it's it's
a really hard challenge to try to give
you both so you guys brought on a new
CEO fairly recently right a guy came
over from from Instagram so what is the
what is the thinking there and like what
are the what is he bringing to the
equation well so it's this is also a
good lesson I think we've learned over
the years and through a number of
experiences which is you the needs of
your company evolve that includes the
needs you know who you need in
leadership positions even up to who you
need in it as your CEO and the history
of Strava mark and I had traded the CEO
position between us by that point a
couple of times and we both recognized
that there were two factors one was our
own capacity and you know what we were
able to sign up for was really limited
for a number of factors and and the
second thing was really that part about
the evolution of the company what the
company needed was someone else besides
the two of us running it and the way I
described it when we were the board was
trying to trying to decide whether you
know sort of how we were going to
navigate this and we've met James and we
thought highly of him James Quarles is
our CEO
I described as like Marc and I are the
dad's driving the minivan to the Grand
Canyon and everyone is in the backseat
and they all want to stop for water and
they want to stop to take a picture and
and we need we need someone to just
drive the van
he's someone to get us there and so
maybe that's part of the the realization
is that James came in with great set of
experiences that really suited for where
we were as a company he understands the
value of value of strobus tied to the
value we provide to the community that's
where the value of the company comes
from and I think he's done an extremely
good job at leading us forward from that
point which is now it's almost two years
in actually so really kudos to James and
and the ability that what he's been able
to do to drive the success of what what
kind of changes as he implemented or
what what what's for direction is he
putting in place I would start by saying
just a renewed sense of just the
importance of growth for the company the
growth of the saying you know they're
there plenty of more if I like to think
about is like 10% of the world's
population wakes up every day saying how
do I want to be active
we've met 5% of those people we got a
long way to go yeah 38 million is a lot
but like there's a lot of people on
point exactly so it's like we've let's
let's let's be really conscious of how
do we get Strava into the lives of more
and more people because they can benefit
from it we think we make the world a
better place by have making people you
know encouraging them to be more active
and that makes them translate into
better partners and better that our
colleagues and our parents because fuels
their their own sense of meaning and in
their day so I think that's good that's
the renewed sense of growth was I think
is super important to invigorate
invigorate the the team inside the
company as well as just in terms of our
community so I think that's that's one
of the big contributions so far this
year you know in his tenure he also just
he brings a set of experiences for years
Facebook for years instrument before
that and before either of those at Dell
and so forth is some of that large come
experiences in
valuable just understanding processes
and scale inside the organization it's
one thing terms of growing our community
but it's also just how do we grow more
effectively as a as a company perfect
example he did a phenomenal job within
his first few months of really
spearheading our move to open up for all
intensive purposes almost a second
headquarters in Denver I mean our
headquarters in San Francisco but
there's just tremendous energy for this
office that we now have in Denver and
that was that was James he he drove that
initiative from day one he saw the
strategic benefit of opening up that
office and allowing us to begin hiring
and building teams out there and what
that should look like and how to develop
leadership there and being one of the
people who probably convinced Michael
that moving from Hanover to Denver would
be a good idea and things like that but
I just I looked at James as somebody who
who has an appreciation for what that
next level of growth looks and feels
like I'm happy and what do you what do
you foresee is your biggest challenges
to take that next step to grow like what
what are the things you're trying to
overcome right now
well I'll say one because we were
talking about it earlier I think it's
always a challenge to remain authentic
yeah to your existing audience while
you're continuing to try to expand the
opportunity to a broader population and
so we we're always looking to walk that
fine line how do you remain that
aspirational brand but also how do you
meet the needs of like our cycling
community you know they're not to be
forgotten it's not as though that was
what got us to here and now we're moving
on it's how do we serve them as well as
we possibly can as we expand into other
sports but also just other categories of
activity and experience so what are some
of those other categories that you're
wanting to capture and how would they be
captured on the platform like if you're
a football player or a basketball player
or something like that that doesn't lend
itself naturally to yeah we haven't
touched the team sports today but we've
taken a lot of interest in what happens
when people are indoors you know so much
of the world doesn't have the benefits
that we have in California where we can
train outdoors twelve months out of the
year a lot of folks have to go inside
one of the best writers we've had is to
realize we can't do it alone so we've
had a great partnership strategy we
literally now have tens of thousands of
API partners who work with us who maybe
have developed a great indoor training
app or something that allows them you
know the examples I would use would be
swift or peloton fries and integrates
perfectly with peloton just you know you
go you have your peloton experience
they're awesome at what they do and then
when you're done it gets uploaded
estrada so that you have that home for
your athletic life Strava is that one
place where you can pull all your
activities into one place that's a
that's a great way for us to think about
how we continue to expand but we do it
as a platform with lots of partners yeah
and there's more and more of those app
developers for a particular sport for
example yoga or core strength and they
will use that API to get their act you
there they're their users activities to
come up into Strava but then it benefits
them because through our feed there's
more awareness oh there's a really cool
app for yoga I want to try that too
because I do yoga I didn't know you
could add that to Strava so it fuels
everything that we want which is we want
our those partners to be successful we
want people to upload more of their
active life onto Strava and interact
with it be able to contribute that to
the community so they get the benefits
of that the motivation that comes from
contributing that and then strata I
think ultimately we we we have not had
to build the yoga app ourselves because
that's that's at all talents that would
mean again building a parallel team
that's really passionate about yoga
that's gonna be challenging to do for
every every single sport out there have
you thought about developing like
in-person analog experiences in the way
that like Nike has their run club and
it's bringing people together in person
whether it's through like like a pop-up
or like a retail you know outlet for
Strava that could be a community meeting
place there's a great example of what's
going on right now in London I've just
and I have to admit I'm just reading
about it and catching up on it but it's
in partnership with New Balance they've
opened a pub
serving beers but the idea being that
you go out and you run certain segments
in that neighborhood and you sort of in
a sense you earn segments
Ward's that you can then go back and
redeem for beer here that's pointing for
creativity there yeah you know that so
it's bringing that run community
together in that local area and so forth
it's a great way for us to brainstorm
and experiment with partners and think
about how we scale things together this
we have a renewed effort on the United
States this year where we've got a new
team we're marketing folks are really
going in at a local level in fact I
believe we just finished the maybe you
want to talk about this East West in LA
oh yeah yeah I've noticed that I see it
in my feet but I haven't like clicked or
yeah East versus West who can accumulate
the most kilometres right right example
of just just being super local focused
and really thinking about the platform
is a way to fuel people's motivation to
be active in something that kind of it
maybe it's a little a little bit of a
you know just sort of local to this this
area but it's like yeah that makes sense
I I'd like to be part of that team
that's going out against that other team
but really I'm doing it myself just
going out to go for a run yeah but it
gives you that little extra layer we
used to talk about that with with your
gut says like what straw was really
doing it's like you spend 30 minutes an
hour 90 minutes out
being active Strava makes magnifies that
strug does something that makes it feel
like either it was it was worth more or
you got more out of it or you learned
something more than you then you would
have if you hadn't used drama and so I
think that's in a good example where
this is this is the platform coming to
life in a local way and it's not quite
us putting on a race or an event where
we say now you have to show up this
point this time in this day it's
separated a bit from those those
requirements of which we normally think
of as a participation event right but
it's everybody every bit as motivating
and fun and and in some ways rewarding
for you to participate yeah in that way
but on a super mass yeah Ville as
opposed to a community or an exactly
yeah
one of the one of the developments that
I've noticed is is this move into
becoming more of a Content platform like
about a year ago you opened it up to to
allow athletes to post like little mini
blogs and things like that and now how
you guys out you just launched a podcast
recently right how dare you
what were we thinking yeah I guess I
guess it comes from thinking about every
activity is a story mm-hmm and so Strava
and already is full of content strata
and it's how do we get some of more of
that content to come to life I think
there's a great you know sort of a great
TV show coming out of straw at some
point no plans to do that now but just
thinking about in terms of what you know
what you might want to turn on and watch
for for fifteen or twenty minutes might
be might be a stream of stuff that's
coming from people's activities around
the world and great photos and someday
will that video I promised but that
sense of like all the stuff this this
athlete generated content is pretty rich
and yeah you know the best best two or
three percent of that content is amazing
stuff so how do you get that to life
bringing that to life and the podcast is
a good example where we we had some
voices that were really really really
rich and interesting and we saw their
stories and we wanted to give them give
them a platform so I think it's really
at this point still very much an
experiment which we do a lot of it's
Strava sort of our ethos is to try keep
what's good hopefully respectfully
discard what's bad and and and that way
learn learn how to serve the athlete
better about the podcast the things been
really well received we've heard great
feedback maybe it's uh it's partly what
people are interested in hearing is the
stories about specifically about sort of
challenges you face that either you face
because you're active as an athlete or
because or things that by being active
you will can overcome those challenges
and that's that's been the theme that
we've been we've been mining now yeah
it's pretty cool I mean there are some
really you know like amazing notable
stories that have come out you guys have
done a good job of creating these
beautiful blog posts out of some of
those like the guys that that scaled
Everest without oxygen you know a couple
beautiful long you know it's sort of
more like immersive interactive blog
posts that showed all the graphs and
data and photographs from something like
that you know rich out are you one of
the best parts of being a founder here
is that we were privileged enough to see
the emails and the letters that come in
to strata so we can do those things that
are curated like with a
in Everest and so forth but every week
we'll get another story from a community
member and the impact it's trauma had
and that's that's what makes it worth it
that's the why that's the why it's it's
yeah well I could bore you but we could
go on for the next two hours with just
ya story after what's your favorite wine
you know Michael never talked about I
wanted to drive up here there's a there
was a there was a great one here's one
forty seven-year-old mountain biker down
in Texas happy as a clam on strawberries
got his posse they love to compete
against each other they go out every
weekend training there's just one thing
that's bothering him which is every time
he looks at Strava his heart rate was
about 20 beats higher than all of his
buddies and it didn't make any sense to
him why he would be faster and stronger
and more fit but why is it heart rate
high so again a long story short he ends
up going to his primary care physician
who tells Maya you've got an athlete's
heart don't worry about it ends up at a
cardiologist because he still doesn't
make sense
cardiologist does some tests and it
turns out he has what's called a
Widowmaker he's just one ride away from
a from a major heart attack and so he
ends up going in and having a triple
bypass and rights to us because he was
completely asymptomatic he felt great
but this one thing kept nagging him on
Strava and it's not because we're in the
business of showing him it's already was
we're in a business of entertaining
we're in the business of having him have
fun with his buddies but he was honored
enough that this thing was giving him a
signal and he was smart enough to go and
have it checked out and now he's he's
back riding this was a year or two ago
but when he wrote to us he was just back
walking and and starting back so yeah
the Widowmaker is the killer man it is
takes a lot of lives that's an amazing
story yeah so it's fun to know that we
were there yeah cool in this whole
entrepreneurial journey that you guys
have been on I mean obviously you know
you you launch a startup there's gonna
be a million obstacles and moments where
you're gonna want to quit and you think
you're gonna fail what are some of those
moments and and and how did you get
through them you know as I'm just
thinking you know as somebody who's
listening to this who's who
a start-up entrepreneur or trying to
start their own business what are some
of the principles and things that you've
learned along the way for you know the
fledgling entrepreneur out there well I
reckon you talked about authenticity and
it's the principles upon which you found
it Strava but one of the strongest
lessons from Khanna and first Rob I
think is that that listen to your
customers if if they are finding value
in what you're doing if they're if
they're seeing something and are
responding you know whether it's they're
telling their friends in the case of
Strava or or they're they're coming back
and wanting us to do more for them in
case of kana in terms of what kind of
features we could build into the into
the product that's the biggest signal
you have that you're onto something and
don't listen to the investors don't
listen to your own internal voice that
says well you know this is a lot harder
than you thought it would be if your
customers are saying this is amazing I'm
really happy that I met you I'm really
happy I'm here then you're on to
something and I recall many many dark
days in both kana and strive aware we're
kind of searching for is this really it
is this is this is this are we on the
right path and then we would would get
the the signal from you know somebody
writing in the saying Straub is the best
thing I ever ever best app I ever used
or you know it's now now I downloaded
yester now it's on my home screen you
know on my phone and those kinds of
signals were we're often the the little
boost we needed to say okay so yeah this
is a challenge right now where maybe you
can't hire the person we wanted to hire
they took another job or or are we
looking at how much money you know the
early days before we had raised capital
like how much our own money we're
putting in the company wondering like
okay so what's the run rate here I'm how
much gonna be how much longer can we
keep going and that that was that was a
really important thing for me that sense
of the signal you can get from your
customers yeah I'm gonna throw it a
caveat because I know that we have 38
million customers listening right now so
we are trying to receive a million of
meritless their lives now right now that
the ritual podcast and we are trying to
listen to you but when there's 30
million of you we may not be able to
actually solve every one of your
problems so I'm gonna put that caveat
out there you want to
customer service seriously but I also
know there's a lot of folks who are very
upset that we haven't got their feature
quite right after two or three you're
right what is it what's the feature that
everyone keeps bugging you like with
Twitter it's like can we edit the tweets
like what's the one thing and everyone's
bugging you to change a long list a list
one that's just been truly you know
contentious is we switched from a
chronological feed to an algorithmic
food like every social media yeah when
it reaches reaches a certain point right
I didn't even know that and a couple of
good reasons we thought actually the
biggest one is again going back to sort
of how we think about things we want to
we want to serve the athlete and part of
a part of the challenges if you have
more than just a handful of followers
you're you're you may not have enough
time to get through your old your old
feed and and so we want to make sure
we're showing at least the stuff that
you probably going to be most interested
in first and then eventually you get
through everything you haven't seen
already and that's the in theory that's
the way the feed is constructed now with
an algorithm that that tries to rank
what you could be looking at that you
haven't already seen and then and show
you the highest ranked stuff first but
boy it's challenging for for many people
who for a lot of reasons and I think
mark you can speak to so can you toggle
that can you go back to home yeah now
you're these are the debates right this
is like why don't you toggle it
no no giving cusper you know you don't
have the choice to dance no I have the
choice to go back to phonological well I
want to make sure that I get to see what
Killians doing before you know Aunt
Betty thank you so although Aunt Betty
may need more cuckoos that's right Betty
she used the Kudo and probably more
motivated than Kilian because he's
getting him off a lot of them here's
mine so everything is moved to video now
we're doing Instagram stories and and I
like to share little video clips like
I'm when I reach my halfway point I'm
way up in the canyon somewhere it's hey
this is what it looks like you gotta add
that come on yeah it's great that you
can upload a photo but how about a
little video clip or a series of little
video clips that can make that
experience more
immersive like I can go on Instagram
stories and see Killian doing his crazy
ski thing but like if I could see that
on Strava and get that same experience
there it seems more integrated and and
you know that's that's true to your
platform and what you're trying to do no
it's like we totally sound like you
haven't thought about now that's right
we're at a hundred percent agreement
that's you know definitely one of the
aspects yet the guy from Instagram so
one of the challenges we call the noise
of opportunities like there are so many
things we could do and so but this is I
mean honestly this is what people you
know people ask what's the determinant
of success and a start-up is like
picking the right things to do first
yeah because you have been patience you
guys that's sorry I interrupt no no it's
I it's it's patience is is important I
think where we boil it all down
we know video is important and it's a
heavy-lift there's no debate but it's
not it's not a simple thing to add in
theory it's like everyone can collect
you know create the video how do you how
do you get it to come to life how do you
store it all though how do you make it
accessible around the world that you
know and we also have to think in terms
of bandwidth we have as you we've talked
about millions of users many of them in
places where bandwidth this is not as
easily accessible as it is in the in in
in Europe and the United States but that
said so list is competing with with you
know maybe 30 or 40 other things and
some of them are must-have can't do
without they touch things like user
privacy and and security of our data and
things like that we got to get that
right and then other things are you know
just competing for we've talked about
them for many years and now it's the
time to do them so videos on the list
promise can't give you a timeline but
yeah right Dulli nice some point duly
noted
all right explain to me this this new
route builder thing I haven't I haven't
actually experimented with that yes it's
still in beta or is it what is it wide
now any if you're if you're on straw the
summit you have a summit subscription
you have access to it as a early release
and so that's you know we're getting a
lot of feedback
from from people who have used it for
the first time and and are learning sort
of what we have to do to bring it you
know up to standard that we would feel
would be be ready for general release
but the idea is first of all to give
summit members something special because
they're they're paying for the
experience but then also learn more how
to make it even better and make it
available and and in some form to
everybody so the way it works is simply
you you have a map and you want to you
you know where you're located and you
know what you want to sort of end up or
a rough route you want to take you just
draw your finger on the on the screen
and we then query our database of all
the decisions people have made about do
I turn left to a turn right which trail
do I take if I want to go kind of that
way
uh-huh and that information feeds into
what route we actually recommend for you
so it's a way of effectively
crowdsourcing your route you have the
benefit of all day all the potentially
hundreds of thousands of other times
people have tried to go roughly that way
and we try to show you what would be
best for you and then you can you can go
in and and modify it further so that's
the essence of the hopefully simple to
use on a mobile phone that's that was
what we're shooting for yet powerful
enough to give you the right route right
so you can like literally draw your
finger on the screen from one place to
the next and then it just comes up with
the route but then when I'm out running
and I'm let's say I'm in a new city like
I love to just go and run a new city I
don't know where the running routes are
but then when I go out running how do I
remember all of that like without having
to stare at my phone to see which way to
turn so one of the challenges but you
can save the route but we create for you
you can save it and then you can you can
use that route in your record experience
on the app or you can you can download
the route to your to your Garmin device
other other devices as well I believe so
you can use it now the question is how
you gonna know you're on the right path
right that's what you'd love to have
like audio queues or yeah and whistles
whatever it is to sort of turn left here
to you in and so that's that's sort of
the evolution of where that I say to go
to give you what you're what you're
thinking about right so you'd have to
look at it go and just make a mental
note of it or sort or get all your
remember the turn-by-turn turned right
on right calabasas or yes it's cool I
like that
any other things you got in development
that you can publicly share yeah well I
know closer yeah yes a little bit closer
so we are focused heavily this year on
something you probably will never notice
in this country but we are focused on
unimprovable of everything around straw
the upload experience that wait how long
it takes for your feed to load and this
is particularly important for Android
and for countries where bandwidth is
lower right where your where your
bandwidth is actually at a premium and
that's coming from the fact that this is
this is where a huge source of growth is
we we live in a in a iOS data data rich
country and so we forget that that most
of the world is you know actually 70% of
the world is Android and we're you know
you're you can't you can't think about
sort of bandwidth without thinking about
cost the countries where this is
expensive for the people who live there
so we're focused on performance and
quality and and things that go along
with that that does now that may seem
like it's not top of the user experience
it's not with something somebody's
interacting with but we feel that
investments there will pay off when in a
few months we turn to things like
discovery which is you know taking the
route Builder that we the route picker
that or the route drawer that we just
have talked about in expanding to the
like well here are three or four
different options for you based on what
we know about you you'd like to run this
kind of stuff here's what we recommend
instead of doing that - slightly
differently so moving into discovery is
an area where you want to have a really
good performant app so that you can get
more of the right content down to the
down to the athlete so it's an
investment that we hope is going to pay
off big when we can turn to more athlete
facing features one of the things I
always remind people you know 80 plus
percent 82 percent of thing today of our
membership is outside the United States
yeah
and so what Michael is alluding to is
just our experience here versus what
we've come to learn the more that we've
talked to our greater community or to
different experience there it to be
really careful with our San Francisco
employee base because living in the
middle of Silicon Valley just the way in
which strata
forms is fundamentally different right
so it's that's right been an area that
we just had to address if we're gonna
continue to meet the needs of this
global audience ten years from now
what's the vision for Strava so it's
funny cuz I I told my go on and a drive
over here I would not say this publicly
because it's an internal thing but I
think it makes sense we're gonna say it
anyway which is Anza listening we yeah
if those 30 million Strava members who
are all on today the we get really
excited internally about creating the
the next great sports brand on the 21st
century I mean it hasn't been done yet
on digital yeah the nikes and the adidas
and the Under Armour's of the world I
mean there's there's some great iconic
brands that have been built in sports
but they've all been built with apparel
and footwear so it's so excited about
what Strava can mean to this global
audience to this active athletic
audience and ten years from now I think
I loved how you asked earlier about sort
of what's sort of that in president I
forget the exact phrasing but sort of
what can we do sort of on the ground
with folks you know how does digital
impact that we were sitting at lunch
before today's podcast talking about the
influence we can have on events and the
way in which we can reshape the event
world let's draw I mean to just imagine
what's possible there we start to work
with people who are trying to put on
events not to disrupt disrupting in a
positive way just the impact that we can
have there so for me it's all about just
continuing to curate this brand in a way
where we know we're serving that
audience and just thinking about
expansion out into these these other
categories yeah it's cool well we're in
this tidal wave of the self quantified
itself you know as we were talking about
at the outset and it seems to me like it
would be a little bit of a tightrope
walk between trying to be I mean you
guys have been really good about
understanding your core audience and
building out from there and I think the
temptation would be like well now
there's meditation and I've got my aura
ring for sleep and you know I use
headspace and and I have to go to all
these different apps like let's
integrate that experience into one place
and as
just thinking out loud thinking about
that that kind of blows out you know
that that that aperture is too wide for
what your core audience is right now so
it's like how do we how do we capture
those who want to quantify their daily
experience and really dial in their
health and well-being versus being like
maintaining the fidelity to the athlete
you know lifestyle
mm-hmm well I think it's we we do talk
about this quite a bit like we part of
that next 10 years is getting a lot more
of those athletes out there to connect
to what motivates them and help them
find their personal best and so to some
extent you have to start asking a
question like what what else would they
want us to do for them and do they want
us to bring in meditation and maybe
sleep measurement and well sleep not so
integral to the athlete you know
lifestyle and experience to be able to
really be able to you know quantify that
and in a very real way that has tangible
positive impacts on your athletic
performance absolutely I mean that
that's where in the ten-year sweep it's
certainly in the view and it's it's
something we would consider and it's
just questioned like where do you put it
in the order and is it something we're
acting on and you know before 2020 or
something that's more like second half
of that ten years but certainly in this
in the view of that ten years arc and I
think the way if you may be helpful to
understand how we view where do good
ideas come from and often they come from
the people who work at strategist we're
pretty self referential we many of us do
love to be active and most of us love to
be active and so we have come up with
ideas as we use Java but the majority of
our our direction comes from actually
talking to our community and researching
what their needs are and we we developed
you know we have a team of people who
are involved in this and we're trying to
get get good insights from actually
talking to people as opposed to just
talking to ourselves so and we hear we
heard these themes again where you know
how could strauber be a more impactful
part of their life what could it do for
them it includes these things like
nutrition and lifestyle and and that
touches into areas of health that are go
beyond just your your choices about how
you're going to be active today
yeah the beauty of being an athlete it
never stops
it's just where are you and they
continue where are you in your life
cycle right so you're either you've
either set a goal and decided to go
after something with the vengeance and
sort of what are all the tools and
services you need in order to accomplish
that whether it's a team whether it's a
coach whether it's a proper nutrition
the right for gear then you get injured
you're in another part of the life cycle
okay what what is it to recover from an
injury and and how can we avoid that
injury the next time you ask over ten
years I think we can put the athlete
aperture on all those categories that
you talked about within quantified self
but with that athlete lens right that
allows us to stay true to our audience
cool all right we gotta land this plane
but let's close it down with maybe some
insight for the new athlete who's
listening in this may be the person
who's you know finally ready to get off
the couch they got to lose twenty thirty
fifty pounds
they've never been a runner they don't
on a bike but they're inspired they
realize it's time like you know I can't
live this way any longer
but they're intimidated they're scared
you know they don't want to go to the
bike shop and be judged or you know it's
just it's a feeling of insecurity to go
to the running shoe store and try to
figure out what what kind of looking
shoes to get you know what can you say
to that person about what your platform
can offer well I'll start I think we
offer something that's that is unique
and really important which is there are
like-minded individuals just like
themselves who are their own Stronach we
have the community that will be
supportive and no one is going to pay
attention to the pace or distance the
person does that I guarantee a great
photo and a funny title you will get far
more kudos from the Strava community
than any kind of performance so don't if
you're one piece of advice do not worry
about what pace you're going at or how
hard you're working out just go do it
just start sweating and I guarantee that
Straubel will be supportive yeah I've
never had anyone comment on any of my
posts like oh you're you know you you
think your fear not that you know
just there's there really isn't that
kind of negativity that you see on other
platforms so I would add to that just to
to think about what what Strava can do
for you when you're just starting out is
is it's it's just that we talked about
this people motivate people and so
connect to others find them you can
connect other social media in Strava so
it finds the people who you're connected
to on Facebook and other other social
networks already in Strava so you might
want to connect with them follow them in
Strava they might follow you back but
that that connecting to other people is
that step that I think completes the
loop for that person who's just starting
out the first run may not feel great but
if you get a couple of kudos from some
people you know you'd be like okay I'm
gonna do it again it's the goal is in
the beginning for anyone starting out is
is not about how fast you can get going
you know how fast eventually you'll be
able to run it's about making sure you
don't stop you don't decide to get back
on the couch and I think that's really
where Strava it brings you into this
world into this community where you're
as Mark said you're it's super
supportive where people are there to you
know experience your highs and lows and
you know if you're if you're willing to
post that activity but maybe it's a two
mile one mile run you walked part of the
way it doesn't really matter but they're
there to support you and pretty soon
you're gonna be running three miles
you're gonna be running five miles they
ain't gonna you're gonna probably think
maybe I could even do a half marathon
that's the way that we see so many
people come into being active using
Strava awesome thank you gentlemen
thank you Thanks how do you guys feel we
did it I think I unless we're out on
bikes well yeah
and then we'll upload this verbal come
this this verbal workout to just Rafa
yeah but no I we could we could do it
again tomorrow we'd have a completely
different conversation I know that's the
view we'll come back and once you get
video going
38 million people expect video tomorrow
yeah let's do it
I'm open to it yeah for sure
cool so Strava calm sign up for summit
you can follow mark and michael on that
platform you can follow me
easy to find there anywhere else you
want to point people that's it that's
pretty much it that's the place right
that's it alright guys thanks so much
appreciated
[Music]